hello daniel hines hello and welcome to
another gamespot now playing what are we
doing today we are playing invisible inc
which is a ink turn-based procedural
stealth game from clay entertainment
what did they make they made a game
called mark of the ninja which was a
really cool stealth platformer they also
made a game called don't starve wow
which is a procedurally generated
survival both of those are great games
both of those are great games uh and
they also made a game called shank which
is about shooting i remember that
one that was a good game and so
invisible link is their latest one and
it's still in early access it's still in
early access this game has actually been
in alpha access for about a year
uh and i've been playing it since they
first released it and i've seen it sort
of gradually become better and better
and it used to have a different name is
that right yes it used to be called
incognita yeah which i think is a really
cool name
it's a really cool name but invisible
ink is also pretty clever it's a pun and
i really like puns especially really bad
puns and i'm kind of coming to you know
i'm coming around to it awesome and the
phrase incognito is actually still in
the game oh cool yeah yeah yeah
well let's get right into it okay
so what are we looking at sorry this is
uh this is a guy with a rifle uh he is
one of the unlockable agents um
so what i'm gonna do is actually just go
to my save file which is this one oh
you're playing on an easy dance i'm
playing on easy but trust me this is not
actually easy this is a really difficult
game it's a lot like x-com in that yeah
you have to think about every single
move uh and there is perma-death as well
so if you lose an agent they're gone
forever that's the type of game i like
yeah i'm sorry i'm assuming it's like
ftl and that easy is still really really
hard yes
it is it is a lot like that normal um it
changes the amount of money you earn
from safes and that kind of thing so
just to take it back a step the idea is
that we control a team of agents who
have to infiltrate corporations right
and steal things from those corporations
so they're a gang of thieves we're a
gang of high-tech thieves but it's got
this kind of like 60 spy but high-tech
like
mixture of stuff kind of like team
fortress 2 but meets mission impossible
like something so so what are we looking
at it looks a lot like x-com and i'm
assuming that's a massive um influence
you know x-com uh i think yeah more the
original x comment it's very grid-based
movement we can click on an agent and
we've got their uh movement radius here
and the uh the blue area
there's also a foggle wall which is why
we can't actually see
beyond this elevator that we've started
in
what we can see though is this red area
here and that means something is looking
that way that's either a a guard or a
security camera or something that will
alert or cause a disturbance if we cross
it so avoid the red basically avoid the
red what we can do though is we can
actually peek around corners using this
ability so it'll let us see what's there
without them seeing us that's pretty
cool so i'm going to do that with my
agent international here
and we still can't see completely what
it is so we're going to go over this
corner i noticed that corner's got a
slight bit of red but
yeah uh the um mouse cursor will tell
you if you're going to move into
somewhere dangerous okay so
it's uh it is sort of a bit more binary
but you do get enough information to
make an information it's very well
signed posted yeah so let's peek around
that corner again and we can see that's
a security camera okay so each movie
dude takes up uh a point of action it's
an action point yes yes it's it's not
like uh the x-com remake where you can
move and then you can shoot it's like
the old school x-con where you get a set
amount of action points and uh moving
depletes them using an ability to pleat
them
however attacking doesn't deplete them
you can attack once per time
and there are certain abilities like
opening doors which are given yellow
icons which don't deplete an action
point so there's kind of a mixture of
stuff you can do and stuff you can't do
per turn i did notice that the attacking
actually has a cool down penalty though
yep so uh our weapon is a taser okay we
don't really have any guns so far it's
it really focuses on close combat which
is another kind of uh
deviation for what you might think of as
x-com i actually kind of think of this
as a bit more jagged alliance like more
kind of hardcore very good uh so we have
this camera and we want to get rid of
this camera what we can do is go into
incognito mode this is where they've you
know used the name from their previous
name right hit space
and we get this sort of hacking overlay
that shows us all of the electronics in
the building
it's very cyberpunk you've played like a
shadowrun returns decker uh it's very
similar to that except this is available
to us all the time and your protagonist
right there is called decade oh he hey i
didn't hey hey there you go also blade
runner reference also blade run the
reference and he has a cool trench coat
yeah okay
uh so this security camera is gonna cost
one power to hack okay we have this
ability uh called a parasite that costs
one power our total power is up here
right uh and we acquire power by running
around
and physically hacking things with our
agents okay so we're gonna spend a power
to hack this
the parasite is on there and it's uh
after the end of this turn it's going to
turn the camera over to our control okay
and it won't be a threat anymore and we
can also see through its cone of vision
but for now you just need to wait it out
and avoid it we just need to wait it out
so i've still got some movement turn uh
movement points with international she
has a thing called the wireless emitter
so i'm going to use it
and it's going to pick up any
electronics through walls within the
radius so we found this safe here safes
usually contain money or items or
weapons
they're really important
so
what is your overall objective in this
current stage in this current stage my
overall objective depends on the type of
building that you infiltrate
so there's different types of buildings
there's like prisons there's vaults
there's executive suites
uh a prison is where i was at the
mission before and i rescued um where is
she back
because i rescued her from the prison
she has no items at the moment so i've
got to kind of protect her and be
careful with her for this uh mission
uh but yeah right now i can't actually
remember what building we're in
but uh we're gonna go through and try
and earn as much money as possible and
upgrade our dudes and i notice you uh
just before then you hacked that safe
with the parasite through the wall so
you don't need to be able to see
anything to actually hack it you just
need to be aware of it you need to be
aware of it by acquiring line of sight
or by using the wireless emitter after
that you don't need line of sight to
actually hack it awesome okay cool so
let's go ahead and move deckard here now
we can our agents are silent when they
move
but we can go into run mode this gives
us extra action points so we get like an
extra four action points we can move a
lot further but the enemy's going to
hear that if we run near them and
they'll come and investigate the
disturbance right i want to run at the
start because i'm pretty sure there's
not going to be anyone around too close
uh but you never know
still being a cautious speaker there
still being cautious speaker now that is
the other angle of the line of sight
from that security camera yeah so i'm
not going to go up there
and i notice that decade has a lot more
ap than um the other two ladies yeah
yeah so dec and i have upgraded uh quite
a bit um each agent can be upgraded with
uh
stealth abilities hacking abilities um
their inventory space awesome and
basically yeah you give them more move
points or allow them to use uh kind of
larger tiers of items so
i'm going to move him here and keep him
at the corner just for the next turn so
we can get to that door
so it seems like you just need to wait
out until that camera flips over exactly
yeah banks is um really cool because she
has the natural ability to unlock doors
this red door is a door that usually
requires a key card
and you have to get that key card off
the body of a guard right uh but if i
have banks i can just unlock it by
beating near it can't do that yet
because the camera is right there but i
am gonna just bring her up here next to
international just hang out and just
hang out so so is there a limit to the
amount of agents you can have on the
field at a certain time it looks like
there's limit of four but i've never
found that without completely dying okay
it was so rare to actually find my third
agent anyway that i'm kind of like all
right this is cool i'm just gonna play
it easy for now
and uh try and keep him alive as long as
possible
keep it in the bank keep it away keep it
in the banks so let's go ahead and end
our turn let's see what happens
so alarm increase what does that mean
dan so
every building has this kind of
autonomous alarm system that is
constantly closing in on your location
right uh and every turn the alarm level
increases by one and starts filling up
this little uh pie chart
when it gets full
and it increases by a level
something will happen so for example
extra cameras will activate extra guards
will get deployed uh extra firewalls
will sort of be installed on these
electronics they might take longer
exactly yeah yeah so it just gets more
increasingly difficult yeah so speed is
speed is of the essence the idea is that
you can't turtle in this game it's not
like excellent work i'm just going to
sit here and wait for them all to come
to me okay you have to actually fan out
and move and
be proactive but also be really cautious
so there's this kind of um tension risk
reward that's constantly happening great
all right so let's move decade up to
this door we can actually peek through
doors without opening it oh we're like
looking through the keyhole like looking
through the keyhole although he didn't
actually look through the keyhole he
just looked yeah
the peak animation is kind of
generalized so they look everywhere but
um
it looks like there is nothing in this
room so let's just
well that was a waste of that was a
waste of turns let's go back out here
there's absolutely nothing there there
is absolutely nothing there the levels
are procedurally generated so
sometimes that happens and it's a bit
annoying but whatever
let's move banks up to this door so it
pays to be speedy but it's all it also
pays to be extremely cautious it seems
yeah it's really interesting that like
you are constantly weighing up um the
risk of certain actions and and that
kind of thing so it's uh
a really interesting kind of push and
pull
all right she saw another safe so we've
opened that door we've seen the safe
we're gonna hack that safe
and it looks clear
but we don't have enough action points
to move in so i'm gonna get
international
and run her into this room
and go up to the safe and then i'm gonna
actually search it
and get the physical cash dollars got
the physical cash monies
uh this would be a good time to explain
the cover system so there is actually a
directional
stealth cover system what does that mean
that means that if i go up behind the
safe you see those little eye shield
icons so you can back up against one of
those two i can back up against both of
them at the same time oh okay and so
anything looking in that direction won't
see me right uh and because i don't know
what's gonna come through that door i'm
gonna hide behind this safe that's a
smart idea and plus she'll be in the
right spot to actually access it next
turn once the parasite kicks in yeah
now i think that is all i can do so
let's intern
ah okay what's that that is a god's
footsteps so you heard that yep i heard
that if you are in
hearing range of a guard and he starts
walking the game will show you the
direction he's taken interesting so
it does a lot to try and communicate
information to you without giving you
too much to work off
so obviously if he leaves hearing range
i can't see where he's gone but i just i
know there's something there i know i'm
gonna have to deal with it
so it paid to uh sit still for a while
and just
observe your surroundings really yeah
now you know to be extra cautious
sometimes i mean like if i play this
game by just running through every
single door i would die within three
turns so instead i'm gonna peek through
this door and see if i can get line of
sight
there he is so he's got his back turned
to you what can you do from here
to me so
i could run in and find some directional
cover such as this gym equipment here
in real life you'd probably see someone
crouching behind that but for the
purposes of the game that is cover
awesome
so
uh the other thing i can do is predict
his movement so i can click on him and
this costs an action point right
and i can see that he is going to walk
back that way but i predict does that
mean that's actually where he's going to
move yes that's actually where he's
going to do so it that's what i mean it
tries to give you this information but
it's going to cost you action points
and uh
it just sort of allows you to plan a
little bit better okay now you can see
that there's some uh line of sight
coming up here i don't know what that is
i think that might be another guard
because guards have
peripheral vision right and they're
actual kind of right which is the full
red stuff
yeah
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
hide behind this gym equipment
you're still running
i'm still running oh actually no no uh
each turn it resets back seriously
sneaking
so he's going to be covered from three
different directions there which is
pretty cool
what i'm also going to do is set him to
melee reaction mode
it's a lot like overwatch and xcom where
if someone you know moves into your live
site you'll take a shot
instead if someone moves next to me i
will knock them out with my taser
awesome without being detected or
anything ah it depends if there is
another person also looking at you okay
okay it's mostly safe to do that but uh
it can you know backfire on you
so we're gonna go and take the stuff out
of this safe
he's got very big pockets she's got big
pockets
i'm gonna look through this door
okay
there
is i think another security camera
i noticed that red um
uh area is not coming from that visible
security camera in the corner there yes
so this security camera is one that will
be activated after this alarm level goes
up
you can see those cameras where they are
and it'll give you a warning when
they're about to activate okay uh but
it's just sort of like this area is
going to get more hostile soon is there
a way to head it off and sort of hack it
before it comes online actually no
because it's just physically turned off
it's not on the electronic system yet
uh so what we want to do here is find
what's causing this
line of sight i'm gonna open the door
and then peek through it again because
if you peek through an open door you can
see more all right
okay that's a turret right that is a
turret now that is actually uh
more dangerous
there's two things we can do with the
turret we can hack the turret itself
right so it will come over to our side
and it will shoot at any guard that
moves in its line of sight or we can
hack the power source and just turn it
off for good okay
the reason we'd want to do that is
because every guard
has a heart monitor
and if a guard dies
the alarm level goes up a lot wow okay
so you actually don't want to kill
people in this game you want to try and
just knock them out and keep them
subdued
but if worse comes to worse you can
start killing people but you have to
deal with the consequences yeah so it's
really encouraging just a ghost style of
gameplay exactly like this is a hardcore
proper stealth game right you know as as
much as in every sense of the word
really
no um killing every single one uh every
person in the level and dumping on their
bodies in the bathroom
style gameplay here no no i mean like
you can uh choose to play as a guy who
has a rifle right but he only gets two
shots really okay and then you have to
like get ammo out of lockers or off
bodies and that kind of thing that's
very interesting yeah
we are pretty much
done all we can do i'm gonna do a
wireless scan again just in case
nothing new interesting let's see what
happens
so he just walked out of um the range of
your taser there is that correct well
there's a kind of um
he can't move diagonally i see or well
he can but he chose not to i guess so i
could actually
slip in around there and that's still
cover but i do want to check where he's
going to move first
okay
all right what i'm going to do is move
here
and i'm going to be safe he's not going
to pass through there
but i'm going to go to melee reaction
mode again just in case
this turret has turned off as you can
see and we can turn that back on and off
again whenever we like
uh so i'm going to move through here
and
with international
i'm gonna peek through the store oh i
ran out of ap whoops okay that was
interesting i noticed you've been
leaving extra ap at the end of each turn
do you get a bonus next turn if you do
that you actually don't it doesn't
conserve ap between turns so there's not
much point to it but sometimes there's
just not nowhere to move all that kind
of thing so better be safe than sorry
yeah
now remember banks has the ability to
unlock doors so what i'm going to do is
move her in through this room
and unlock the door for decade so he can
actually come through with us great uh
and then we should be we should be
golden and you can avoid um taking out
that gold all together yeah yeah oh okay
we've actually got sight of the other
guard here so
and he's elite he has heavy armor oh
that is really important that means my
standard taser can't knock him out
however
i got an upgraded taser with deckhead
did i or is that the same one
oh god i can't remember
it looks to be the same it was
international who had it
oh okay all right so basically i'm gonna
have to avoid that guard forever okay
so he seems to have more proof more
vision he has a wider vision cone then
yeah yeah it looks like it um also
because he is stationary i think he's
remaining stationary yep okay
yeah that's gonna be a problem we'll see
what we can do there's a lot of um
distracting guards by like opening doors
in their line of sight and then closing
them so they're like what the hell was
that yeah i was just about to ask you
about that yeah or like running past
them but you know maintaining visual
cover and that sort of thing so
basically the enemies can still react
during your turn
they will react but they won't move
right they'll say hey what was that and
you'll get a marker saying next turn
this guy's going to come here and
investigate that so
i hope you're uh someone to think about
i know i know there's a lot of thinking
alarm level one so this has
gone through enough turns that's going
up to alarm level one because we're
playing on easy nothing happens on alarm
level one okay it's alarm level two that
we have to worry about
and that will be after another five
turns
um so what this power drip that gives
keeps giving you plus one power so power
drip is one of the hacking programs i
chose to start with right when i made my
campaign
basically every turn this is generating
one power for me you'll notice that this
parasite costs one power to hack stuff
but i haven't hacked a lot so i'm
basically breaking even as far as power
goes fantastic once the firewalls get
more complicated we're going to start
running out of power and this will
become really useful
all right i'm going to peek through this
door because i didn't get to do that
last time well it's a lot of red oh
that's a lot of red interesting a
missile
a missile oh yeah look
i never actually noticed that okay
this console
will give us the location of every
single camera in the building so we're
gonna hack that
that seems incredibly useful it's very
useful yeah
um it won't hack all the cameras that
will just tell us where they are
we're also going to go in
maybe look through this door
that's relatively safe but we just spot
another turret we did spot another
turret it doesn't seem to have a power
source
but or perhaps it's concealed
oh yeah it's possibly concealed in that
square we didn't get to look at
now this has a daemon attached to it so
if i hack it
the building security is going to be
like whoa what's going on and start you
know freaking out and so it might raise
the alarm it might deploy a guard it
might stop my ability to hack for a few
turns so there's kind of a risk in
hacking that i don't really want to hack
it right now because i don't need to
move through there just yet
but i am going to check out this room
here
and maybe just hide behind this batch of
missiles which probably won't go wrong
and close the door behind you nice
exactly yeah
uh now this door i don't really need to
unlock because it leads into the same
room
so i'm just going to move up here
and move deckard here and be sure to
close the door behind me so this guy
doesn't accidentally peek through
very meticulous style of game super
duper meticulous
close that door and
let's see what happens
hearing that god hearing that guy
control
and so now we've hacked that um camera
mainframe yes and we see every camera
however all the cameras that are left
are ones that are going to come on with
the next alarm level right so we don't
actually need to worry about them yet
um
now what i can do to get access to that
turret power source is use
international's wireless
there you go so now i can see that
and that doesn't have a daemon so that's
going to be the safer one to hack
it's interesting that you can't
automatically assume the same of each
sort of enemy yes um by sight you need
to actually go in and analyze what
properties it has exactly yeah a lot of
that is randomly generated and it's
going to really change the way you try
and approach a situation so it could be
extremely punishing if you were to
neglect one step
exactly yeah yeah you can very easily uh
alert the entire building
but there there are sort of ways to
compensate for that and and you know
hide or
respond in some way
all right i'm going to keep her there
i'm going to keep her in melee reaction
mode
and
i think i'm going to keep my agents
no you know what that guy was stationary
so i can start moving him in i think
so you're gonna try and sneak up to him
yeah well
i forgot where he's actually looking so
let me just peek
ah okay
that's hmm lot of red it's a lot of red
and we're going to stay here for now
because i'm not feeling very good about
that
but we're going to melee reaction mode
just in case
there we go that's a grandpa simpson
walk in the door
do a loop and walk back out
okay that turret is off
i do want to see what's in this door
another there's a lot of turrets a lot
of turrets in this level
turret factory right okay so we have uh
a safe i'm gonna hack that gonna turn
that turret off
and i'm going to move you in
so this console here is what provides us
power right if we didn't have that power
drip program so i can hack it
oh here we go someone has left their
email open
so we can read uh corporate approved
memes and jokes
bank account info or
is it can you only pick one or can you
go through we can only pick one oh i see
and the result is sort of like a
randomly generated
all right awesome what should we do ed
well
i want to look at some jokes but i'm
assuming bank account info um would be
pretty useful i mean it's not too much
because you don't have anyone with a gun
you know actually i currently have 1400
which is actually a lot of money oh
really okay so i think we can afford to
listen to that look at sami's jokes
after being bombarded with pictures of
inoffensive animals and catchphrases
international feels totally energized
movement refreshed that's amazing so you
actually get a perk for
looking at dumb stuff yeah
yeah it's not just a waste of a thing
uh quite often refreshing your movement
is
probably more useful than that's right
it's basically another turn exactly yeah
i'm going to hide behind this safe i'm
going to go to melee reaction mode oh
actually i can just do a wireless
interesting that doesn't pick up guards
does it no no it does not only
electronics
this is a shop so you know how in
roguelikes you might occasionally find
your shop
uh that's basically what that is but i
do need a hacker to use it so let's
start hacking that that turn
melee reaction use a hacker to spend
money on it exactly yeah doesn't make
any sense yeah it's uh it's a very uh i
guess kind of stuffy or stingy building
we're infiltrating
now
i'm going to hide behind this console
with banks because remember she doesn't
have a weapon
so that's right interesting that you
have less sight of that now yes yeah
yeah
um i'm gonna hide behind this corner
maybe
yep that's safe
oh just in time oh okay there's a whole
other room up here i didn't even see
that
is this a heavy guard no he's not so i
can taser him which i'm probably going
to need to do if i want to get in there
that's right
is are there distraction tactics
yes if i was running yeah
and i ran up to this corner here yes
this guard would hear it and he would
come over to investigate
and i could just taser him in reaction
mode so that's a really good way to sort
of lead people over to you and they'd be
like hey
yeah we'll try and take it to someone so
i can show you because it's actually
pretty cool but we'll just hack this
safe first
i think that's pretty much it
interesting that hacking things from a
distance is so like easy and little risk
but everything else
yeah and also that was a big sound
that's a big sound it's because we
hacked two safes at once oh that's not
there and this one that international
was hiding behind so let's just open
this first
oh okay we have an emp pack
disables all mainframe devices in three
tiles that's pretty cool interesting
in case you got in a bit of a sticky
turret situation it's a sticky turret
situation
sticky turrets are the worst always
always something to watch out for
this red door here
is like a lift where extra guards will
spawn if that alarm level gets to i
think it's alarm level 3.
so we want to go in there and buy some
stuff but we want to be careful
to not spend too long in this room
so is that always the case like level
two is cameras level three is more
guards currently yes uh playing on the
harder difficulty will
move that down one level so everything
happens quicker
but uh yeah that's pretty much the case
for now i'm just gonna peak again
into this door once i've opened it
two consoles in here awesome
i'm not gonna hack them yet because i'm
at full power almost so
yeah
now
i'm gonna have to taser the sky but to
get you a better view i'm gonna rotate
oh you can actually rotate the camera
you can rotate that camera oh wow
all right so let's do this
oh jesus so the interesting thing is
when you taser someone it pulls them
into your square
now he isn't dead he's knocked out for
three turns
however if i stand on top of him
i'm pinning him right i'm basically
pinning his throat closed
so that he
is he's kind of staying unconscious
right and the three turns won't tick
down and as long as i'm on until until i
leave his body that's very interesting
yeah so
however if i'm on his body i can't use
my melee reaction right so you're
basically stuck there you're sitting
dark basically yeah but what i'm going
to do now is i'm going to
steal something from his body 150 bucks
and
i am also going to start moving his body
because i want to keep him knocked out
but i want to kind of gradually move
through the level as well
so let's go back to our original view so
by moving his body do you still manage
to keep that
countdown yeah he's still knocked out
and he won't start the countdown until i
leave his time
yeah so you're basically like holding
him in the sleep hold for the whole time
because my next question was like after
three turns what
tactics do you have to prevent him from
waking up or to prevent him from being
alert
uh you could shoot his body with a
lethal weapon if you had that right
um
or usually if their body is about to
wake up your main tattoo is get the [ __ ]
out of there right so it's it's kind of
like uh
we've changed the situation now we have
to act quickly rather than we have
permanently removed this threat
uh banks is going to go up and get
something out of that safe i'm hoping
it's a weapon because she really needs
one
so
saves aren't just money it could be
anything it's no you can find anything
that's safe money uh
items called corporate intelligence
which play into the metagame which i'll
talk about once we get there
uh and yeah a whole bunch of stuff
all right so i'm gonna run in
oops
no oh i haven't ended my turn yet okay
let's go
i'm cleaning crease there's another
garden i'm really glad i didn't run then
because i was thinking maybe i could
just get banks to run up to that safe
but if i did he would have hurt me and
we'd be in a world of trouble because my
taser is still cooling down
and i can't use it oh actually i have
two tasers no
okay
i found that taser in a safe so what's
the um the hearing range is it like 10
tiles
uh it's a bit hard to tell because you
only see that sort of white uh
ring that emits from footstep but it's
kind of hard to translate that into an
exact tile but basically you just got to
be careful the older version of it used
to have the exact range and they kind of
took that out to make it a bit more
ambiguous which i'm you know it's fine
it works
what have we got
more cash damn it just cash maybe you
can hack the shop i did yep so we hacked
the shop so let's go and run in
to the shop
what have we got
you're the shop do you want some
satacistic pumps
killing adds 3 ap wow okay
so that's interesting you can get like
augments uh that are sort of like
passive abilities however this character
can't kill anyone because they only have
stun weapons right so that would be kind
of stupid to buy
uh so there isn't like a fist option
unless someone is specifically trained
in martial arts say you know i haven't
found a martial arts character uh the
only character with a lethal weapon has
been the guy with a rifle right who you
saw on the title screen what i want to
do is get this neural disrupted too
because this goes through armor remember
that heavy guard that we can that's
right
armor-piercing one yeah that's it so i
can upgrade my inventory to buy it
uh which i am going to do
so let's
put that in there
now there's also this oracle which is uh
and a hacking ability
this is really useful for the start of
the game
but
are you a pro at this now you don't need
that well yeah and remember how we had
already hacked all the cameras yeah we
don't really need that just yet they
will come online next turn though
you're right you're right so um
and i have a lot of power to spare you
know what let's buy it
let's live dangerously
so that just upgraded your um
existing
so now i have this extra ability here
yeah and i can't use it because i have
all the online connections it takes four
power four power so it's something to
spend our power on which is always nice
uh
we're gonna just run the hell out of
here and try and meet up with our team
you can see what i've done is i've kind
of gotten a bit too separated and i
don't want to start moving into an
unknown area until i regrouped
that's going to take time though like
every turn that passes it's going to
be a bit bit hectic and i'm assuming you
know much like xcom when you have to
exit the level they all need to do b
together yes we have to get to the
elevator and we all have to be in the
elevator there's like a single point of
exit
yes okay yes there's only one you can
exit one at a time but the elevator
becomes unavailable for a couple of
turns nice and then it comes back open
right again right of course so it can
lead to some very tense situations um
i'm going to drop the body
all right so that now you've got a three
turn countdown yes now i have enough ap
to peek through this door
and come back
and hold his throat down let's hold his
throat down
but i'm gonna maybe just okay i don't
have enough ap to drag him so i'm just
gonna choke him out
and get a quick layer of the land
there we go
so it was worth it
all right additional camera is activated
we got one turn okay so there is time
for you to hack those cameras before
they fully come online yes see how they
have this uh warning siren
so i'm gonna jump in and hack that like
that
just hack everything yeah it's a really
good um chance to actually see where the
level layout is as well because often
it's it's kind of hard to tell which
direction you're going in
whether it's the correct one
i can't remember there was a guard in
here in this room right yes he was
patrolling the gym and there was an
armored guard just by the bunks okay and
they were in the same room yes right he
was stationary yes so i
i can run
but not too close
or on the outskirts yeah yeah
one more okay
that's good
now
there's a guy you probably need to deal
with because that seems to be
yeah you need to explore north west and
south west what i want to do is is get
uh banks down here to get the taser off
international
but i can't remember if you can uh drop
weapons for people to pick up yet while
you're in a mission yeah yeah
tonight so you just hacked that tunnel
to get yourself more yep so we got back
to 20 power so does the team share a
pool of power yes so basically
think of like this ability as the
operator back at home base whoa
hey i'll hack this camera for you it's
not like us physically hacking the
camera that's a really nice uh narrative
idea it is it is yeah
uh i'm gonna look through this door
oh not very much
line of sight wow that's really nothing
in there is there
what a useless room
okay
well there could be something in that
look there could be but like one of the
odds right yeah
there's no safe there
okay we'll move you you're not running
are you good
can you
tag team
um
people on that body so yes that's what
i'm planning to do she's moving down
here hey banks hold on to this guy for
me exactly so because she has no weapon
she's actually really useful at just
like keeping people down nice i'm going
to run them up here and try and deal
with this guard while international is
regrouped oh okay cameras are on all
right
i think you're good at it but they're
about to get hacked as soon as i
there we go oh okay so you didn't even
need to wait for a turn because you
already started the hack class yes yeah
they come online
which allows you to hack them but their
vision doesn't happen until the turn
after that right all right
banks keep him busy
now i can't run because there's a guy
right there so we're just going to
move silently as far as possible
keep in mind there's also this store
which we haven't looked in but there is
that heavy card there so i don't really
want to risk that there could be a door
in that corner
it could be
it could be but you know
all right
all right
oh he's gone out the other room so he's
safe for now but he might be back yeah
so i'm going to show you how we actually
distract people okay uh once
you know what i might move this body
just closer up here now he's he's gone
to the two countdown
there's no way to take that back up is
it um
just like you can buy
tranquilizer projectile weapons like a
pistol and in the old version you could
shoot a body and that would reset his ko
count right i haven't done it in this
new version though because i've never
bought a right tranquilizer pistol yet
hypothetically hypothetically you could
because you can
kill him in that state yes the idea is
you probably track him as well exactly
yeah
oh he's back
oh what's he doing
now i could distract him or i could just
run in and tase him which is what i'm
going to do it's the smarter option
just happen to be looking at a wall yeah
that's what he gets we'll take advantage
of that what's he got
okay he's got a pass card
and
168 credits it's a very sad looking
guard i know he's just like oh man
again
now we've got enough ap to move through
and take a peek let's do that
hey there's the exit so can you exit
right now yes so basically your
objective is to basically uh sweep the
floor i have to encase the joint as
thoroughly as possible
and i think for this mission we've been
pretty thorough we could go back and
investigate here but that's risky it's
so risky and uh
i just kind of want to get out away from
this two-turn ko guard
i don't want to run yet but oh look just
enough to pin this guy
and uh
yep that should be fine
i really like that mechanic because so
often stealth games you just trans
someone and then they're out for the
rest of the level exactly yeah you don't
pay any sort of thought
and the uh the
encouragement to not kill them with the
alarm raising as well is also really
cool
now can i get banks sorry international
into the lift
yes
okay so they can just book it we'll book
it yep we're leaving
i honestly thought i was going to die in
this mission because this is really far
in you've done you've done very well
like i think this has gone so smoothly
like i'm just i'm amazed all right
there we go exit
push the button
clean up costs zero dollars never done
that before
oh
you could all pay witnesses
this is basically a perfect mission this
could not have gone smoother
congratulations dan you really are
you're the ultimate um
invisible i am the invisibleist inc
all right so you're talking about a
metagame yes
so this is the upgrade screen right uh
where we can select each of our agents
and choose what we want to upgrade
upgrading costs money so we have to sort
of uh balance that out with buying
things from shops in emissions
versus actually just putting points into
their stats
so stealth allows you to move further
hacking lets you use more advanced items
inventories inventory space
anarchy lets you do cool stuff like
stealing from guards who haven't been
knocked out okay uh
and
i haven't really investigated that more
there are some items that require like
anarchy level two to use
uh so we have 800 bucks
what do we want to do
the most useful stuff is inventory
because i find that you you come across
more items and you can really carry and
having like two tasers for example is
extremely useful absolutely yeah
so
all right
let's give this guy another inventory
space so but each character still has
their own unique trait
each character has a unique ability so
international has that wireless yeah we
saw
deckard uh has extra movement points and
he starts with a uh cloaking device
which i didn't actually show i see i can
show you that next mission because i'm
sure we're gonna have to use it
banks uh she can unlock doors without
the security card
now i wanna be able to actually move
people further so i'm going to give
international an extra movement point
because she has a weapon that's always
useful
and i think i've spent all my money 50
bucks so is there any reason to keep
your money
into mission yes because you might find
a store in the next mission with
different items that you might find more
useful than what you have currently
okay all right old map this is the world
map and we actually just infiltrated
sydney i think was the last mission we
did so excellent how apt
uh
okay
50 hours remaining before the end of the
game each mission requires a travel time
of a certain amount of hours because
you're going to physically fly in san
diego yeah yeah yeah so
we sort of have to um balance out the
travel time with what we might find in
there
each uh mission also has a different
security level right guarded is like
level one very guarded level two
super gun guarded
do you want to do a very guarded mission
let's try it the city kansas city is
certain
server farms are where we find new
abilities for our hacking
thing to possibly purchase
and re-appropriate
in the building don't miss it i love
this lady she's the person who's sitting
back at home base she's not like uh
malory archer yeah but uh
yeah
awesome now like so with the overall
meta game is is it just to
like hack as many locations as possible
and just reap those rewards or is there
like a pot of money that you want to
sort of hits or i have never survived
long enough to finish the metagame so i
actually don't know
um so this starting room actually looks
quite similar the one we started in
before
but
you can see we can already see two
different doors down here
uh i'm gonna do a wireless scan
nope nothing okay nothing
whoa there are a lot of doors we've got
four doors already
oh look one of those useless rooms i
love those
go up here
but that's that's good because it
represents you know the risk you have to
take and exactly
i should have moved closer to that door
that's all right
you're just running all over the place
decade what are you doing
nothing on that wall
okay we got two people so let's move
those down there and we can just peek up
there on the other turn
may they reaction just in case someone
might come through so that doesn't
actually cost anything to queue up no
that's why it is the orange icon because
that's like your attack ability so
that's like a separate
pool yeah
wow i'm glad i didn't run yeah then
now guards actually can't come through
locked doors so they will circle around
the entire level really the other way so
even though even if they had a key card
say
yes i have noticed that they don't
actually uh do that they will come
through if you've unlocked it okay uh in
the old versions you could lock the door
again which was super cool
they've kind i think they've taken that
out perhaps unintentionally in this one
so once you unlock it it's like well
ready to go for everyone okay
let's unlock it and have a peek
all right okay he is a
normal guard yeah
and we want to be careful of that
location so let's just peek through this
one
all right it's all one room
what do we got up here
okay i should wireless scan here just to
try and pick up whatever that is
it's a turret
love a good turret let's hack that
now i'm going to hack both of them in
case i want to turn it on again and
shoot someone uh
so you use the wireless scan twice
just then uh one per second yes yeah so
you can use it once per turn once it
actually well it costs one ap oh i see
yeah
uh
okay nothing in that gym
i'm gonna go there
reaction
yeah a lot of gyms are these corporate
offices a lot of james you know they
provide good benefits to their employees
because they're uh
the interior design of kansas city is
very similar
that's uh i guess it's all one
corporation i'm assuming you know i'm
actually not sure i think the actual
corporation names are randomly generated
um
in one of the earlier versions you would
infiltrate like a japanese corporation
and all the guards were like robots oh
and that made things super difficult so
let's open this door
where did he go where is he like yeah
where did he go
he must have gone through that oh he's
gone in there for some reason they don't
you should do that because there's
nothing actually in there it's just a
room that's the spawn point
room yeah so does that mean he might be
coming back or is he gone for good
he will come back
so i am going to go over here and get
ready to melee reaction to him while
banks comes in spawn camp i'm gonna
spawn
basically spawn camp the guard
uh okay
all righty
i should probably peek
oh so you can see him in there excellent
yeah
already in melee reaction okay good
we're good to go banks do your thing
there we go there's a safe there's some
red in there
yeah i can't tell if that is security
camera red
it looks like it
is there a different hue of
guards no basically security cameras
don't have peripheral vision so that's
sort of half
yeah yeah sort of if you see that means
that's a guard right you're looking at
his peripheral there
all right this actually has two
firewalls so it's going to take two
turns to happen i see so
what about the turret itself oh [ __ ]
there are two guards in the spawn oh
[ __ ] oh what have i done
oh no so you can only take out one guard
with that reaction oh no oh this is to
go terribly okay this is just what i
want to see okay
you want to get uh international down
there yeah
international has med gel so i can
revive people within a good amount of
time
uh i don't want to run too much because
that will
i'll let you know
i'm gonna stay there okay
okay
oh what's gonna happen all right
hopefully only one of them will come out
of the door yeah but the door's gonna be
open oh i see here we go
oh would that see that door closed i see
okay
so
so now what so he's moved to you but
he's not going to act until the next
turn is that right
so now he's got a little crosshair on
top of his head yeah he is in basically
overwatch mode if i move
within that uh cone he will shoot me and
i try and i die in one hit oh okay
um if i have met joel i can revive him
though
uh but it's it's kind of really
difficult to do so you want to take him
out before he has a chance to do
anything yes but i cannot do it with
deckard because decade is in his line of
sight if i do anything with degrading
he's going to die hypothetically if you
used a second taser you'd still get shot
yes okay yes
you there's a mechanic where you can't
actually use a weapon if you were in
their overwatch line of sight right what
i have to do
is come up behind him
and it's really good that i moved
international down here
so he doesn't hear that when he's in
overwatch oh [ __ ] he's armored oh no
nope nope nope i got neutral distracted
too yeah
oh i'm so glad i bought that in the last
mission wow whoa okay intense
now i'm gonna pin him because he's only
out for two turns because he's armored
right what have we got
take
uh now you are going to take that money
oh extreme
okay
now that turret is still getting
hacked so you can't go in there just yet
you know what i can do what can you do i
can hack the turret
drag their bodies in there that's so
cruel and then
and then run the hell out
yeah we're gonna do that it's gonna take
a couple of turns because dragging
bodies uh is
well it eats up your ap
and that will increase the alarm
significantly yeah but who cares we know
the other option is to have these two
guards tracking us through the rest of
the level
one of whom is armored
and uh i think this is gonna be the
safer bet
so
all right i'm gonna hack that console
wirelessly oh oh oh
automated security program okay
okay we should hack it otherwise the
alarm's going to go up all right
done it okay good
it cost power but whatever so that gave
you access to all the security cameras
no this was a console that gives us
power okay but because there was a
security program we got no power and we
actually ate power hacking the security
program okay everything is sort of like
maybe it'll benefit you maybe it'll harm
you
all right let's bring the body down here
as well
banks what are you doing
just hanging out yep that's pretty much
all i can do right now
okay
hopefully there's no one else in the
area yeah
oh oh no
so because that turret had a demon right
we hacked it the demon is activated
so you have 20 turns to do
some more guards ever showed up so now
you're in um
hypothetically you could get
banks to hold down one of the guards
while decade or international goes and
takes them out yeah but my tasers are on
cooldown
do you not have a second taser but oh is
he i'm not sure if that second one
so is it that an armored guard
it's an enforcer which no they they move
quicker but they don't have arm
okay let's drop the body
let's [ __ ] hope this works
yes okay we're in reaction mode banks
do the thing you're only apparently good
for hauling down dudes throats
and we're going to move a bit quicker
now
i have to drop you to open the door
don't i
so you're still committing to this
dropped in front of the turret i'm still
committing to this because like we've
we've you know gone this path we have to
see it through
oh dear
so that turret will only activate when
they wake up is that correct um because
i hatch the power as well it's actually
off okay as soon as i press that all
right it's gonna get um basically a good
overwatch cone and once they wake up
it'll be like blink blink
and good then
yeah basically hello
uh are we good we're good okay
there we go excellent
just clocked in one
okay
so now you need you have three um three
pawns for the can you see how decisions
i've made like yeah 20 turns ago like
now coming to benefit me or you know
screw me over this is invisible ink
now are you dragging that body yes
should we kill all three of them
well
you're committing wine so you might as
well
throw the rest of them in the grinder
all right
okay
i'm gonna get deckard to um
move him
just a bit further in
just just lay them on the three tiles
surrounding the turret yep it's gonna be
a good time
uh
i really hope there's something worth it
in this door otherwise
otherwise this is going to be if that's
the lift you just get the hell out of
there
yeah we probably could
i still haven't opened this safe
actually
okay
thanks
oh sorry pick him up drag him in
oh she couldn't move him very far no
because uh he has a lot more stealth
points uh purchased so so that's just
primarily based on your ap so it just
has the ap
basically yeah when you drag a body
now i'm going to need to drag them in i
think one more turn because they get a
chance to move
and they could just run out that door
now here's a question yeah can turrets
target more than one person
at a time at a time no okay they target
one and then they shoot and then i'm
pretty sure enemies can shoot a turret
if they realize it's gone haywire okay
so
this could backfire yes
one safe
i'm gonna hack that and just keep
pinning this guy
until my next turn
uh also i'm gonna drop you and i'm gonna
put out the cash make a run for cash
stay pinned good
oh
all right
now i noticed that in incognito mode i
saw that there was a box in that safe
and i've noticed that in previous turns
we've seen briefcases so does that mean
does that represent something different
um you know i have never
paid attention to the shape of the
different boxes i think what it means is
you haven't opened this safe yet okay uh
but we'll find out i'm gonna run this
guy in here and just get whatever that
is
oh that's not enough to pin him but
that's okay he's gonna be dead soon
okay 710 bucks money and corporate
intelligence cool uh
you have no room for that is that right
yeah i can't upgrade my inventory here
for some reason i think it might be a
bug
is that just because it's not a shot
either
probably yeah yeah it's a good point all
right i'm going to have to leave that
unfortunately and maybe get banks or
someone to run in who has
space all the space
all right
some serious hijinks going on seriously
okay we're almost ready
those cameras gonna come on soon thanks
drop that
run
get me some corporate intelligence
okay
bring this back to central to improve
your reputation better pay
so basically more money
yeah and you want to do that because you
unlock stuff for later playthroughs with
what you actually earn during this
playthrough
uh
okay i'm gonna have to just
maybe pin him because he's on 2k
all right next turn i'm going to run out
the door i want to get you out quick
oh dear
i'm looking forward to this additional
cameras to the camera right above you
yep hack that
uh and you know what let's let's take
control of around the camera
uh i don't know what that did
i don't know okay maybe that was the
only camera possibly possibly
now
the thing is i'm not going to be able to
see what happens unless i stay in the
room or near the room so you want to be
able to just like peek through the
keyhole basically yes so i'm going to
keep um international here because she
has two tasers in case someone comes out
right i'm just gonna like stay in melee
reaction
i'm gonna run you the hell out of here
and now you're gonna turn on the turrets
i'm guessing uh
good point
thank you so that does that cost um an
ap point no once i've already hacked it
i can do whatever i want for free
and look i might as well just get you
ready to
start moving up here
now this is gonna happen for two turns
yes because they're all chaos for two oh
look we synced that up perfectly
wonderful
how much time we got left
enough enough all right
i like how this is an example of
something going terribly wrong and we've
managed to
hopefully hopefully
um rectify the situation here we go all
right
oh dear
okay what happened there they got shot
did they not i'm not entirely sure i
think the turret
shot the armored one
i see so he managed to survive a hit
possibly yeah
okay look you can stay in uh melee
reaction mode you guys can move up here
ah there's the camera we took control of
ah okay so you couldn't actually see it
even though you had taken control of it
yeah i think it had so well it had to go
for one turn so actually
all right let's see what happens here
oh god are they going to destroy the
turret
he's down hi
see the alarm went up by two turns and
firewalls are upgraded so that means it
costs more to oh turret's down
okay okay
that didn't go as well as i had hoped
yeah
but it is now time for international get
the hell out of there so our turrets one
hit
turrets as in do they die in one hit
i've never tried to shoot one before um
i think he took two hits then because
remember him one common firing
i'm running they didn't hear that
because they're you know concerned with
that
just we just woke up and there's a room
with a turret exactly
uh let's check out this room i know some
footsteps up there oh really yeah way up
here north
just right there
oh hey yeah good spotting didn't see
that okay hates the observant in this
game it really does
whoa all right lots of red what are you
gonna do here hack everything so that
increased by one i'm assuming because of
the alarm level yes that's right and
that camera did which is why they
haven't ticked over this turn yet either
all right
he's coming to that door i'm in
cool all right actually that's what i
want to do unless he is actually armored
in which case
you might be screwed
ah he was looking that way
he is not armored is that not a separate
guard
that's the same one he just turned
around before we'd actually open that
door
more stuff to hack in here though bam
bam bam
now i'm going to close this door
melee reaction
so that he gets a nasty surprise
uh banks
let's have a gun
buy a gun or a junk pistol
click this weapon aim and shoot an enemy
all right yeah gun a dagger ammo
breaks through firewall oh so it's not a
physical dagger no no anything with a
blue icon okay is for incognito
um
you know what that's pretty much it all
right she's now my pistol here
that's what she uses to rob banks i'm
assuming hey
so you found banks just jailed you know
yeah and i had to rescue her and get her
to the elevator uh and once i did that
she became part of the team so
interesting i saw deckard just get him
through the door the door opening
animation
uh doesn't actually exist yet i think
like they open instantly so as soon as
he opened the door that meant he was one
tile
next to him and he just went he got him
what we got money
just pilfering all their wallets yeah
yeah like that
so that is all
locked down because
i opened a demon so i can't hack stuff
yet ah interesting oh look she looks so
cool with a gun that's awesome
i've actually never had a unit with a
gun before so this is really exciting
yeah
let's have a peek
all right there's definitely a guard
there
oh
i'm gonna close that door quick smart
yep
now
so you can't hack that safe just yet no
because i'm locked down
but i will bring banks into i think
this room over here to help decade
uh there's no point in him moving in yet
but i can move the body
right
oh oh oh
where's that aragon
you damon installed that's interesting
why did that happen
uh i think i finished hacking this thing
here because incognito
oh i just got re-locked down again
so i just shot myself on the foot
uh he is looking at the door i'm pretty
sure
yep oh interesting it's interesting that
it keeps what you last observed on the
screen until you repeat yeah i think
what's happening is you are sort of you
remain peeking through the keyhole and
unless you move away uh you're still
going to be able to see that stuff so
all right i'm staying in my reaction
mode wait for him to move back
i can't hack that yet
but i can go over here and see what's in
the server oh i shouldn't be running
because he will then hear it
he'll just walk through the door unless
i want to do that
maybe you do maybe i do
okay so he was like hey
that means he's moving to this uh square
this grid space but she's there ready
for him
what have we got hammer breaks fight
firewall
ping make a distraction noise that is
what i want
yep
it's interesting
so we can now well i can't do it now
because i'm locked down but we can
basically make a distraction noise
anywhere on the map for a certain amount
now okay that seems super powerful yeah
just lure all the guards in the level
yeah yeah
the turret corner
basically that's what's gonna happen
oh sorry there we go
oh
where is the exit it's got to be through
here the large door yeah yeah i'm
getting a bit antsy because i don't know
what these cards down here okay they
move from there that's all right
banks what's up
coming in this guy to move
okay here we go
all
right oh oh [ __ ] he's going all the way
oh no
wow okay so we didn't know there was a
path there
yep so what we can do uh
oh there's a door right there okay so
you're gonna set deck it up um
is he cooling down no he's not
so actually i might just send
international in because i need to go
through here anyway
i can start hacking that
okay yep so he's now heard that
also he's through the door yeah okay
uh
whoa whoa i'm glad i did not yell
through there
so decade is still your best bet
yep but he is going to come down here
now so i'm just going to go highlight of
course
uh what we do know is there's nothing in
that room which is good so i can move
deckard somewhere more useful okay so if
the camera sees you take down a guard
does that
does that punish you in any way ah
it depends if
the the punishment will happen first
because if i step in that area this is
going to increase by one right uh and it
will keep increasing by one for every
turn i remain in the cameras
it doesn't tell the guards where i am
though okay so it's not an automatic
alert no no it's like a
thermal detection sort of thing
all right come up here
i've just got to keep babysitting this
guy otherwise
he's going to wake up i hope the lift is
down here
oh no
where can the lift possibly be i don't
know there's a lot of stuff so let's
just hack all of that oh you know what
through here
i haven't gone to this door yet
that means you need to go
back if it's down here somewhere i am
screwed because those guards are moving
up now it seems oh [ __ ]
you're right
oh what can they just oh [ __ ]
do i have enough ap to close that i do
not
bad decision decision-making you always
got to close doors in this game it's
it's uh it's very meticulous gotta be
meticulous
so
i might have to abandon
that safe
because i'm getting worried so let's
start moving down here
so you've left that guard now also
which card the one you're putting down
is that right oh she is grabbing his
body but i'm gonna yeah next turn i'll
just leave him
ah you know what banks
if you go here you'll be out of their
line of sight so
that's good you're closer to the safe
sorry
so one more guy patrol but they'll spawn
back oh no oh no
different location
oh no
oh no he went around that way
so that guard walked through that door
yeah despite despite him hearing you uh
international in the top left oh god
this is all going wrong
that's okay
you know i have faith in you
okay i can't cloak because he can see me
so he spotted both of you so
but only one can possibly die
has he spotted has he spotted banks
um well
it says the location is being watched by
the enemy when you mouse over her tile
yeah
you know what
what are you gonna do dan
uh i'm going to switch to international
i'm gonna [ __ ] book it
i don't care about the camera scan
because that only just adds one yep
alarm level hey buddy
jesus
hold on got some money
take your wallet
uh we have to get the hell out of here
um
this is
very risky now this is super risky so i
know there's this guard here i know he's
going to start moving in i know these
guys are moving into patrol
uh
but you don't know where the elevator is
yeah
all right you know what there's a turret
in that room
oh oh oh reframes
yes oh cool so that's just uh
now there's not much i actually can do
with her yet because
she is on cooldown
i am going to run
you're going to
be kidding
me where is the where's the exit is it
there's another card is it through the
other door this one yeah yeah it's gotta
be i mean i don't know where else it
could be
uh
which is gonna make life hell for us
so you know what i'm going to go here
i'm going to melee reaction mode i'm
going to turn this turret back on
yep good i hacked that okay
put a blood bath yep yep it's getting
getting pretty hectic
now if you run
take cover by the turret yeah that's not
gonna be dangerous at all
do i wanna
overwatch [ __ ] i've only got one bullet
make it count yeah exactly
uh
all right you can go here
okay what's gonna happen
so he's walking up is he gonna open the
door i know he is blocking that space
though
so what's that another garden moving
through
i believe it is the guard who was um
go out of incognito mode thank you
what are you gonna do dan
you know what i have to close this door
to block that line of sight i think
uh and
huh
so that door is open
he's right there
i can't mail him though because he will
go into overwatch and that's going to um
change the condition of the attack as
soon as you move into that tail right so
i'm going to stay in melee reaction mode
i am going to
run here close the door
i am going to get seen but it's going to
block the line of sight to allow banks
to come down here and go into melee
reaction mode okay i think so you're
saying that
in the in the solid red color that will
trigger the overwatch mode exactly
and in this one it'll make him turn to
look right and then potentially trigger
overwatch if you stay there all right
but i just noticed this guy is looking
here which is going to cross banks path
so i have to close this door in his face
does he not notice that he notices that
so he's going to come through again
right
all right let's let's make this work
okay oh
okay no we're good
okay
all these dogs are closing okay so
close this door as well gosh there's a
lot of thought to be heard yep
melee reaction mode
oh [ __ ] no
why is that is it because you're taking
my other taser sorry my other taser is a
melee reaction taser um
are you in the door
you are so i'm gonna have to run banks
back here
okay
if he comes through i can manually use
my other taser right
and whatever i'll just hack unless he
goes to overwatch right
ah yeah i don't know it's gonna be it's
gonna be tight all right let's see what
happens
okay overwatch
it was a second guy
oh [ __ ] so he got tasered by a decade
he oh no no international
so why did that happen
is it because
he just saw her
i'm yeah i'm not entirely sure i think
it's because he was straight in because
one of them triggered the sight in one
of the triggers also he's an enforcer so
he may behave differently
so
my options right now
cloak i'm gonna cloak
all right i'm now invisible
uh
how long does that last
one turn one time so i have one turn to
do something
what i want to do
is run
taser man
taser bro
that's okay he's just saying i saw
someone
can i taste bro
oh oh
balls no i can't why can you not taste
him
uh if i have two of the same weapon i
think it bogs out it's just you know an
early access thing so
let's just get through this door and get
out of here
so you're leaving
you're leaving international and banks
to die so here's the thing international
has the med gel right you can't revive
herself did i not see they could have a
piece of magill as well oh no
ah what have i done
okay all right so
she has a gun is he in overwatch mode
yeah
so he's looking right at her
the turret i noticed isn't doing
anything
[ __ ] it shot him
okay alarm two
the turret isn't doing anything but
uh is this watched by the enemy yes it
is
okay i'm gonna have to run up here yes
close the door get this guy to run up
here and then get deckard in to revive
international so there isn't a cooldown
of like she will bleed out for x turns
before she really dies uh i i haven't
noticed that okay i think it's just you
can leave without them or you can try
and ride back
okay i shouldn't have wasted that cloak
that was done
okay what's happening okay another guy
got oh no oh no oh no they woke up
oh interesting now you're trapped in a
room with two guards okay
all right dan
so he's an overwatch
yes but i'm not in his overwatch cone
okay i think
so
oh this is tense
can she act immediately i'm not sure
she's got ap yes she can act and now she
can tase that guy
really
enemy is facing the agent
right what if
she moves does she not then gets shot
yeah you know what probably yeah yeah
she probably will
so
i use my other taser which is the super
taser
okay so the [ __ ] out of here why did
that not trigger overwatch that he's
overwatch
um
that is a very good question i think it
is because
these tasers react differently because
they're like secondary weapons right
remember how i shot the other guy before
despite being yeah you know watch range
yeah right
all right i'm getting the [ __ ] out of
here
you're gonna hope that that lift is
right there
i like you not even peeking just like
bust open that yeah yep everyone run to
the left
there it is there is the lift and
there's a turret
oh it's got three
oh wait wait wait wait
do i have a thing that i can
my mp pack dear oh
[ __ ] it prime that emp lady
oh this is gonna be so good if we
actually get out of here
banks really does now if i block the
door with decade it's going to be a bad
time so i'm going to run in
with banks first
deck it has just enough to get in and
close the door and i think they're not
going to know where i am
because they're looking oh cause they're
in the other room yeah okay
oh
all right
so that turret has been taken down
but they heard the explosion
uh i believe someone woke up right okay
oh my god and now you're just gonna
sprint
i really hope banks has enough oh no oh
you got to be [ __ ] all right there's a
wall that's fine
i'll upgrade her next turn you know to
actually prevent that happening
to actually be useful yep
oh you should close the door
excellent
that'll stop him
yep they won't see what's coming
all right
wow
what a
lucky escape
on the max alarm level as well so okay
so that's maximum so what happens now oh
my god
two elite enforcers they're right there
oh my gosh
luckily they haven't opened the door
they actually have you can see their
vision is right there but we because i
moved here in that spot that's blocking
it oh sure you can't see the door that
has been opened bail wow
all right
wow that was incredible
well i think that's a good place to call
it don't you yeah absolutely well that
was a good sort of
uh overview of the highs and lows the
highs and low it it really is about
invisible incorporated peaks and valleys
so high tension in invisible ink so it's
on early access it's on lexus now it's i
think 20 bucks or 25 bucks um i believe
it's one of the most complete early
access games i've ever played well
that's a big call to me i'm still having
a lot of fun with it as you can probably
tell despite its early access that's
amazing yeah because it did go through
one revision already it did yeah yeah it
has changed so much since its first
version and i'm really liking where it's
headed all right well that was invisible
ink yeah um for more on invisible ink
and other stuff please stay tuned to
gamespot until next time dan thank you
very much thank you see you later